الاسبوع الماضي شغل العالم كله موضوع
النزال بين قطبي التكنولوجيا واثنين من
اغنى اغنياء العالم ايلون ماسك ومارك ذكر
بارك فخبر على تويتر سعي متى اللي بيملكها
وبيديرها
بانه الاثنين راح يصير بينهم نزال والناس
بتسال فين والساعه كم الموضوع بدا بانه
ماسك علق على خبر عن المنافسه بينهم بانه
جاهز لنزال في حلبه ملاكمه ومارك ذكر من
على منصته هو انستجرام رد عليه وقال له
ابعث لي اللوكيشن من يومها والتساؤلات عن
النزال هذا الماليه المنصات حيصير او لا
مسح او جد طيب متى وفين ورد جاء من كذا
مصدر والكل بياكد انه النزال قائم
والموضوع جدي مع انه ترى الناس كلها مو
قادره تصدق انه شيء مثل هذا ممكن يصير
يعني حيمسكو في حلق بعد كده ويتلاكم قدام
المليارات من البشر يعني فكره فعليا
مجنونه اخيرا او اخر تاكيد خلينا نقول جاء
من ماسك الي كان مشارك فيه مساحه على
تويتر موضوعها اقتصادي تجاري لكن اول سؤال
ساله كان عن النزال ورد وقال انه لسه ما
بدا يتمرن لكن لازم يبدا لو الموضوع حيصير
واعترف كمان انه الموضوع ممكن ينتهي نهايه
سيئه في حقه خاصه وان نذكر دخل بقوه عالم
اللي هي احدى الرياضات القتاليه لما بنقول
من قوه انه دخل لهذا العالم بقوه ترى ما
بنبالغ يعني من كم شهر دخل بطولات واخذ
ميداليات واللي بيمرنوا واحد من افضل
الرياضيات اللعبه تحديدا فيعني انتم
متخيلين انه مثلا ممكن الموضوع يصير جدي
وكذا واحتمال يصير والناس بدات طبعا يعني
قاعده بتقارن البنيه الجسمانيه لماركو
بيتوقعوا مين حيفوز ناس تقول مارك رياضي
فهيكسب ناس تاني يقولوا لا صحيح ماسك مصرح
من قبل انه ما بيلعب اي رياضه بس هو يعني
اعلم يعني خلص الموضوع وصل لحد الجنون
يعني واكيد حتصير رهانات كمان زياده عن
الموضوع وعلشان يزيد الجنون اكثر مين دخل
على الخط اللي هو رئيس منظمه الفنون
القتاليه المختلطه ال ufc الرجل مؤسس
رياضه
وبطوله يو اف سي اللي بيديرها هي اهم
بطوله لهذه الرياضه في العالم
في تصريحات اكد فيها انه بعد ما شاف
الاخبار اتكلم في التليفون مع مارك زاكر
وجلس معهم على التليفون ساعه ونص واكد انه
الاثنين مو بس جديين جديين جدا وقال حتى
انه عرض يستضيف الحدث حتى في اليو اف سي
في حلبه اليو اف سي نفسها واكد ان النزال
حيكون حقيقي وانه مو مسح او نزال مسخره
بهذه التصريحات اصلا الدنيا مقلوبه عليه
من قبل محبي الرياضه ومتابعيها والسبب انه
اليو اف سي طول عمرها بتبعد نفسها عن
النزالات من نوعيه الاي كلام واللي هدفها
بس المشاهدات والجدل وكده هذه ما بدهم
يخربوا رياضتهم وتفضل جديه محبي الامامي
شايفين انه الدينا وايت كده بيدعم نظام
نزال اي كلام يعني الرجل من ناحيته نزال
الحقيقي وبيوصفوا انه راح يكون من اكبر
النزالات في التاريخ وان يمكن يكون اكثر
نزال يجيب ارباح في التاريخ اكيد ما عندي
شك في هذا الموضوع